welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the book of boba fett is the
mandalorian spin-off series coming to
disney plus this december it's expanding
the star wars universe after we saw luke
skywalker reclaiming custody of grogu
don't worry kid you get two christmases
now we finally have a trailer for this
boba fett series so i'm gonna react to
it give my initial impressions and then
i'm gonna go through and break down a
bunch of details that you might have
missed from it let's check this out here
we go
oh those are the uh the spider things
the big fortuna brain
monk droids
i've heard otherwise i love they got the
dent they better explore that dent i
love the way his armor is all chipped oh
and they did it on the titles too very
cool
[Music]
i know that you sit on the throne of
your former employer
is that mando's voice is that pedro
pascal with fear
i intend to rule with respect
okay
i love it it's
it's like politically cool
captain's under jabba the hutt
i'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial an awful you can't
refuse
why speak of conflict
when cooperation can make us all rich
nice nice
yes yes
she had spoken such insolence to jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie chunk
speak freely
yeah freely
nice
this looks sick this looks awesome so
just to give you a bit of background on
this boba fett's being played here by
the great tomorrow morrison morrison
played jango fett and attacked the
clones and obviously all of the clones
and the prequels and they did bring back
morrison to voice boba fett in a number
of star wars games he actually voiced
boba in the 2004 re-release of empire
strikes back now boba fett we thought
tumbled into the sarlacc pit and was
devoured by the sarlacc and returned the
jedi but he showed up in the final shot
of the season 2 premiere of the
mandalorian when he seemed to be dressed
as a tuscan raider who was spying on
mando taking his green armor later in
that season he followed them to the
planet typhon when they were trying to
channel a jedi from those jedi temple
ruins which we later found out was luke
skywalker he was joined by fenix shand
who we last saw in episode 5 of season 1
the bounty hunter that amanda was trying
to track down she ended up shot in the
stomach and at the end of that episode
was found by some mystery figure who
many of us thought was boba fett and it
turns out it was now the big mystery
with boba fett is how he escaped the
sarlacc that's one question that i hoped
that would have been addressed in the
mandalorian and if they do not address
it in this show at least just to make a
joke about it at least we will continue
asking it until we're in our graves now
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements like they're really
unflattering photos of you for middle
school you're not alone both in
stressing about credit card debt and
wishing you didn't go through a bowl cut
phase upstart can help you make that
final payment so that you can break that
cycle and get ahead upstart is a fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows that you are more
than just your credit score and is
expanding access to affordable credit
rather than looking at a credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com new rockstars that's
upstart.com new rockstars use our url to
let them know that we sent you
upstart.com new rockstars season 2
episode 1 was following largely the
events of chuck wendig's aftermath book
with the character of cobb vance timothy
olafan's character and in the season 2
premiere cod van revealed that he had
gotten this armor from jawas who
scavenged it in the desert but that
season 2 premiere also shows mando
helping cobb work with tuscan raiders to
slay a crate dragon which is huge and
spews acid they specifically say was
larger than a sarlacc so i don't know
maybe the crate dragon devoured a
sarlacc and then used that acid to
devour the sarlacc which would have
freed boba fett to escape and could have
gotten burped up from there i don't know
i hope there's a better story to that i
want to see it in the show so anyway
when we last see the moves in uh season
two episode six that was the episode
robert rodriguez directed he's actually
directing most of the episodes of this
show and mando reclaimed his armor
revealing his mandoa chain code
confirming his father django's history
as a mandalorian foundling and then he
helps dinjon and his crew locate grogu
and during that time he did not get
along with the other mandalorian bo
katan she called him a disgrace to the
mandalorians because he's a clone but he
begrudgingly works with all of them from
slave one he fires on the lamb to
shuttle allowing them to board moff
gideon's imperial light cruiser and then
he jumps back in hyperspace and then in
that finale post-credits scene boba fett
shows up in jabba's palace kills bib
fortuna or should i say big fortuna and
then takes jabba's throne with fenix
shan sitting at the side sipping some
spatuka and now this series is picking
up with that and it kind of looks like a
godfather soprano style mafia show with
boba fett trying to rebuild jabba's
criminal network and assert dominance
over all of them but also change the
rules of the game a little bit because
that was the whole thing with the
godfather right don corleone wanted to
try to have peace among the different
families you didn't want it all to end
up in war because when there's
cooperation you can go further now the
trailer opens with these great spider
droids these are the bt-16 droids used
by the bomar monks on tatooine you'll
notice how it has a little brain bobbing
in the juice there that's because the
bomar monks will transfer their brains
to these droids as they become
enlightened and it's amazing that they
included here because in the expanded
star wars literature this is originally
the fate of bib fortuna after he takes
over jabba's operation he ends up
getting mixed up with these monks and
the last time we see him these droids
are closing in on him about to suck his
brain out and now that story like many
stories in star wars literature has been
retconned by what is now canon to the
cinematic universe i love that they
include the droids here it's just a nod
to that original fate of bib fortuna we
actually saw one of these droids in the
background behind c3po is the enter the
palace and return of the jedi and as it
did then you'll notice the animation
does look a little stop motiony kind of
like fidgety i didn't complain about
that vfx i kind of love it it does
remind me of a lot of the stop-motion
technique that was used in the original
trilogy it also makes this droid feel
kind of like janky and gross matching
the gross kind of movement of a lot of
insects so there's a shot of a droid
handing boba his helmet and i love the
attention to detail they put on his
armor it's chipped it's weathered and as
i pointed out that whole production
design is on all the titles throughout
this trailer too they're all rusted and
worn and most importantly boba fett
still has that dent on his helmet now
this is always a big mystery how boba
fett got that dent on his helmet it
seemed like the clone wars was going to
answer that question back before they
were actually able to produce season
seven when dave filoni revealed the
unfinished episodes there's a storyline
where boba fett was gonna be in a duel
with cad bane a blaster bolt was gonna
hit his helmet and leave that dent on it
i would love that this show could
address that whole backstory either
through a flashback or boba fett running
back into cad bane or something like
that because cad bain's fate was
supposed to be left a mystery now boba
fett is talking to someone during this
it sounds like it is din jaren i've
heard otherwise i know that you sit on
the throne at one point he meets an
ithorian warlord that's a hammerhead
alien race this is supposed to be a
peaceful species like they're
agricultural this looks like one of the
authority figures that boba fett is
trying to win over i love the look of
this giant city that looks like it's
structured in a huge pit it might be dug
out at the top of the screen there is a
ship with a similar design as the razor
crest of course the razor crest was
destroyed on typhon so it's not that
there's a shot of jabba's palace with
someone walking up to it alone i would
think that's boba fett but he wouldn't
have walked right up to that palace
because it looks like he caught them
with his pants down also he was with
fenix shand and this could be one other
local leader whom boba has summoned to
the palace they meet with the captains
who worked under jabba the hutt a big
table with some trandocions that was the
race of bosk and some clutunians they
have the you know
all right you know that now platoonians
were seeing oliver jabba's court in
return of the jedi platoonian raiders
were actually the ones that were
guarding grogu in the very first episode
of the series we never really know how
grosgu ended up in their hands maybe it
could have been some deal that was
orchestrated by jabba we also see a shot
of some tuscan raiders now when we saw
boba fett in that season 2 premiere it
was never really clear but it looked
like he might have been living among the
tuscan raiders of tatooine or at least
has some relationship with them because
he was carrying a gaffy stick and it
looked like a tuscan rifle maybe part of
his arrangement is to broker some kind
of piece with some of the tribes of
tuscan raiders there's a great shot of
some twilight woman jabba and finnick
shand are also flanked by some gomorian
guards this is the pig nose fellas who
guarded jabba's palace there's one shot
of boba's helmet rolling on the ground
and a bunch of coins falling out these
are rebel alliance credits you can tell
from the rebel alliance insignia
remember in episode one of the series
there's that whole debate over whether
imperial credits have any value after
the rebel victory over the empire but in
the series imperial units are still in
control in different areas they're still
a major threat this shot of the helmet
rolling on the ground does evoke the
shot from attack of the clones when mace
windu beheaded jango fett and boba fett
picked up the helmet maybe seeing the
helmet roll on the ground might trigger
boba into that flashback i saw my father
die daddy daddy is your helmet in there
oh my god daddy finnick and boba gets
surrounded by all these red shields
looks like the same kind of shielding
tech that we saw in the naboo palace
that separated obi-wan from the fight
with darth maul and qui-gon and then
this awesome stunt where boba's able to
overwhelm one of these guards steal his
staff and just bring it down with his
awesome face i love how morrison's just
having a blast going full out with this
when we saw him in that season two
episode six episode he was using similar
warrior moves in these warrior
expressions it seemed like he was
pulling from some of that maori
tradition and i love this good cop bad
cop relationship that finnick and boba
appear to have finnick kind of
threatening to drop them into the pit
where boba is the good cop saying no
please speak freely but he's speaking
softly while carrying a big stick it's
just an interesting management style
that's still just as deadly just as
threatening but on the surface at least
giving them an option to play nicely now
they're going to be eight episodes this
season and we know the episode titles
are going to be the champion the
assassin the syndicate the battleground
the homeworld the warlord the showdown
the hunter now one question is whether
or not boba fett's gonna help poketan
liberate mandalore he does not seem
interested in that because technically
his home world was kamino and we just
learned from star wars the bad batch
that boba fett had a sister named omega
boba was the alpha clone of jango fett
she is the omega clone she's the same
age i'm guessing we're gonna see her as
an adult character in this show who also
comes from boba fett's home world also
in bad batch we saw a baby rancor named
muchi we thought this could have been
the same one from return of the jedi
because bib fortuna actually shows up in
bad match to pick up this rancor but the
rancor in return of the jedi was named
patissa who knows maybe moochie and
petito were related but moochie might
have now grown up into an adult on this
show and these characters might have to
track it down i'm just really digging
the vibe from this like so much in star
wars it's about the war it's about
reclaiming thrones it's about the
revolution rarely do we get to see the
difficulty of rule now yes that is
something that george lucas tried to
explore with the prequels right trying
to maintain power the difficulty of
factionalism and democratic rule but
this series is taking away the broad
scale of that and just making it a
simple matter of one political faction
and just making it a simple matter of
one crime organization and then
hopefully we get time to learn the
relationships between these individuals
so it's less about exposition and more
just about relationships that's what
made the sopranos so great and the
mandalorian's been so good it looks like
it's pretty much the same team working
on this show robert rodriguez has
directed a lot of episodes but john
favreau is coming back to direct one of
them dave filoni's directing one of them
bryce alice howard is directing one of
them so it's gonna just feel like an
extension of the mandalorian which i
think we're all on board with but let me
know your thoughts on this trailer and
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching this is the way
[Music]
you